Imamo pravna pravila,
poslovna pravila
koja ima uređenu funkcionisanu državu
i pomenuli smo dva osnovna
principa funkcionisanog država
koja su podlana čelo subordinacija
i koordinacija,
subordinacija i odnos nadređenosti
i podređenosti.
i tu imamo državne grane
na različitom stepenu vlasti,
a kod koordinacije
imamo isti stepen vlasti
i imamo sarade.
To je ono što smo prošlog puta radili
i gde smo se, ja da, zaustavili.
Sada idemo dalje.
Dakle, kada je reč o ljudima?
Krenut ćemo sa ljudima da vidimo
koji to ljudi rade, šta rade,
kako rade i kakav je njihov odnos
prema državi kao organizaciji.
Dakle, državu kao organizaciju
ne čine svi građani,
ne čini svo stanovništvo.
taj državni aparat čine
samo neke ljudi. Ti ljudi
koji čine taj državni aparat,
oni se nazivaju državnim službenim licima.
Dakle, to su ljudi
koji rade u imenu za računu državu.
E sad,
tim državnim službenim
licima se daju određene poslove.
Dakle,
imate potređeno državno službeno lice,
date mu da rade neki posao
i taj posao predstavlja njegovu radu.
Ja se obudim na to
da vam što jednostavnije objasnim,
ne da se držim ti definicije službenika,
nego najprostije moguće da vam objasnim.
Dakle, uzmeš neki posao, daš ga jednom
državnom tvrdnom odliču i kažeš evo ti,
na, radi to, to je tvoja nadležnost,
bukvalno tako.
E sada, postoje dve vrste nadležnosti u
principu i ova treća nekakva funkcionalna,
to je uopšte nije zakonska kategorija,
ali se često spominje,
pa ću na nju objasniti,
i prisutna je naravno
u radu državnih ordana,
ali nije zakonska kategorija.
Da krenemo od stvarne, dakle,
ako uzmete recimo jednog sudiju
koji je državno službeno lice
i jednog narodnog poslanika
koji je državno službeno lice,
da li oni rade isti?